look at this this snake attacks her
they're trying okay oh oh oh let's get
the snake off of her right and then the
guy filming is like should I stop
filming and they're like no keep filming
their whole attitude is like
you know it's like oh snakes are good
don't worry this just doesn't normally
happen let me be perfectly clear
for all you idiots out there who always
send messages about oh snakes are pets a
snake is not a pet when a dog bites its
owner we kill that it's
gone okay when a when a dog bites the
owner we go well the dog has now
realized uh the dog has now lost it we
gotta put it down look
if your pet quote-unquote
if it gets hungry or agitated and it
will attack you
that's not a pet
[Music]